well the first conference of a new party
leader is always a bit different than
the ones that went before but what made
this conference so dramatically
different is what has gone on in the
Labour Party the parliamentary Day party
has effectively had a leader imposed on
it by the grassroots only a handful of
Labour MPs wanted Jeremy Corbyn as their
leader so this will be the first
gathering of Labor tribes since corbin
said action i think we'll begin to see
the dynamic service the korvenites want
to make post-conference more important
because they believe that's how they do
an end-run around these MPs who are
skeptical of a Corbin agenda and we've
tried and possibly been up for debate I
think we'll see the first forays in that
battle
well I put apart from crying into their
Prosecco I think the challenge for them
it is to think about what they want off
of a Labour Party I think that they're
the Blair I prospectus has got very
stale I think the whole label is
actually unhelpful to them and they need
to fall in a language and a champion
that can begin to reconnect them with
the rest of the party
well I mean they're looking at that the
nail casting around for figures at the
moment you know some people like Dan job
it's the former paratrooper officer but
he's much more left-wing on economics
for example than most of the people on
the Blairite were in the party would be
well I think it's very different you
talk to people close to those in the
shadow cabinet and what they say is that
the Shadow Cabinet have agreed to serve
because they can agree with what Jeremy
Corbyn is going to do in their
particular area but they do not think
that shadow cabinet responsible active
responsibility applies across all policy
areas so that's why we've seen Charlie
fault Hillary Ben and others coming out
making it quite clear where they
disagree with jeremy corbyn